I'm Annie Leung and I just broke the Guinness World Record...
...Guitar Hero 3, the highest score for females.
It's really exciting to be able to be in the Guinness World Records.
I'm so excited that my score is able to be out there for everyone to see...
...and it's like the ultimate achievement.
It's gonna be written down and remembered for many years to come.
So, it's definitely really cool.
Being a female in gaming is really hard, actually,...
...because there's a lot of harassment sometimes, and guys kind of underestimate you.
But, you know, I've put a lot of hard work, and commitment into it, and proven myself that...
...I'm just as good and just as much of a threat as anybody out there.
I'm from California. It's where I was born and raised.
Right now, I'm 25 and I recently just graduated from college,...
...and I'm a gamer on the side. It's my hobby and I love it. So, yeah.
The thing about Guitar Hero that I love is...
...the walk and the music. It really gets me going...
...because that's the music that I listen to on a regular basis.
So, it's really fun to be able to play it at home and...
...I don't play the guitar, but it's really awesome to just...
...feel like I am and rocking out to the songs.
I think my friends would be really amazed and excited for me that now I'm this new record holder.
They've always, you know, been gamers too, so they would definitely be really into it, and supportive.
I think this record will hopefully lead to open the doors to many more records.
And I would love to, you know, set as many as I can,...
...and just promote more females to compete and get into gaming and, you know, increase your skill level. So, yeah.